what's up elimination I've got some
exciting news for you and also could use
some feedback over the past couple of
months basically since the beginning of
this year I've made a commitment to
myself to try to reach a wider audience
to try to get the message out to more
people because I think if people believe
in themselves more there's a huge win
for them and for the planet you've seen
it recently with the girl bar series the
black excellent series the somos series
and I'm going to be experiencing with
more serious like that but my next test
is actually looking at going
multilingual some of the videos we've
done we put multilingual captions on but
I'm looking at actually launching
multiple versions of this channel in
different languages and having them
dubbed over I'm looking at a couple
different options of how to do it the
natural dubbing where there's somebody
actually doing it manually each time is
the most expensive and may not pay off
but I'm looking at options the most
promising path and look at is actually
having artificial intelligence AI do the
translation and the dubbing it's looking
pretty good it's not a hundred percent
as you can imagine but it's pretty close
it's enough where if somebody watches it
in a native language they'll be able to
understand it and so I'm looking at
Spanish as my first language and
starting the Evan Carmichael espanol
channel I will see how it goes what I
love to hear from you is two things one
what languages should have been looking
at which languages do you want to hear
which languages do you feel would be of
the best interest for me to go after to
reach a big chunk of entrepreneurs and
help them believe in themselves and then
- have you seen any best practices of
other youtubers doing this I haven't
seen that many examples of people
creating content in different languages
having different channels for at least
doing it on a mass scale I have five
thousand videos - to move into multiple
languages and I'd like to start with
Spanish and if it works then expand
quickly to the other ones and so I don't
quite know where the line is yet of how
far down the line I can go I
my team is from Serbia and is hoping for
a serbian language channel so we'll see
if we can make that happen there's
enough people to digest the content but
that's what I love your feedback on one
what languages should I be looking at
and - have you seen anybody who is doing
this that might be able to share some
best practices or I could examine their
channel as well I would love your your
help your support your guidance and I'm
super excited to launch the the Spanish
version hopefully others at some point
this year in the next and then thanks I
want to say next month I'm going away
we'll see we'll see we'll see we'll see
thank you guys so much the support leave
your thoughts down below I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
right Teemo Teemo whatever year one word
is much love no see you soon once volume
you have the most important work ever if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details